now that we have a decent understanding
of how to figure out how many
significant figures were even dealing
with let's think about a situation where
we're significant figures will or might
become relevant so let's say that I have
a carpet here and I using a maybe a
meter stick I'm able to measure the
carpet to the nearest centimeter and so
I get the carpet as on to the nearest
centimeter I get to being one point six
nine meters so this is this nine
obviously this is to the nearest
centimeter this nine hundredths of a
meter is the same thing as nine
centimeters and let's say I'm able to
measure the width here the width here as
two point zero nine meters I use the
same meter stick and you were to ask me
Sal what is the area of your carpet and
so you know I just do the straight-up
calculation the area is just going to be
the length times the width so it would
be one point six nine meters times two
point zero nine meters two point zero
nine meters and we could do this by hand
but let me just get the the calculator
out just to make things move along a
little bit faster and so we have one
point six nine times two point zero nine
and that gives us three point five three
two one let me write that down three
point five three two one so let me write
this in a new color so this gives us
three point five three two one and we
have a meters times meters which gives
us meter squared or square meters and so
I might very proudly tell you hey the
area here is three point five three to
one square meters and the problem here
is that it when I give you this thing
that has you know all of these numbers
behind the decimal point in all of these
what we now know to be significant
figures it implies that I had a really
precise way of measuring of measuring
the area what in reality I only was able
to measure the area to the nearest
centimeter so the way we would do this
so that we don't so that I don't make it
look like my measurement is more precise
and it really is for this calculation
that's derived from my measurement
I make sure that it has no more
significant figures than either of the
numbers that I multiplied so in this
situation I have three significant
figures here three significant figures
and over here I have three significant
figures three significant figures and so
in general when you multiply or divide
the significant figures in your product
or or or the the product or the I always
forget in your there's the devise or
there's the dividend then there's the
quotient the quotient the the the
numbers the significant figures in your
product or your quotient cannot be any
more than the significant the least
number of significant digits in whatever
you are using to come up with that
product or quotient so over here both of
these have three significant figures so
I can only have three significant
figures in my product if one of these
has if this had three significant
figures and this had two significant
figures
I could only have two significant
figures in my product so in order to be
kind of legit here I have to round this
to three significant figures so I have
to round it to three significant figures
and on either so I'm going to round to
the nearest hundredth here and so this
two will will round down so we go this
gets us to 3.5 3.5 3 meters squared and
now we're cool with the significant
figures let's do another situation with
division let's say that I'm let's say
that I'm laying tiles down in my
bathroom and so the diagram will look
very similar and I measure I measure I
measure the I measure the width of my
bathroom to be let's say it is 10 I'll
do it in feet now so let's say it is ten
point one
ten point one feet and this is the
precision that I'm able to measure it
with so I'm able to measure to the
nearest tenth of a foot and let's say
that the length of my floor the length
of my floor is let's say the length of
my floor I'll just make up a number is
twelve point and
so for whatever reason I was able to
measure this with slightly higher
precision so twelve point zero seven
feet and let's say let's say that I have
tiles I have tiles and the tile has an
area so someone else measured it for me
it has an area of let's say that the
area of this tile is one point zero
seven feet squared and this was just
measured for me and what I want to do is
I want to figure out how many tiles can
fit on this bathroom floor so what I
would do is I would figure out the area
of this bathroom floor and then divide
by the area of the tiles and so the area
of the bathroom floor
so floor area floor area is going to be
equal to ten point one ten point one
feet times twelve point zero seven feet
and so that will give us that will give
us let's calculate it it is ten point
one times twelve point zero seven feet
so give us one hundred twenty one point
nine zero seven one hundred twenty one
point nine zero seven so this is equal
to let me scroll over a little bit to
the right this is equal to I could do a
little bit more to the right this is
equal to one hundred and twenty one
point nine zero seven feet squared or
square feet now we're not done with our
calculation but there might be a
temptation right here to say look I had
four significant figures over here I
have three significant figures over here
there would be a temptation to say look
my area should not have more than three
significant figures and that temptation
would be okay
if this is all you are looking for if
the final answer you were looking for
was the area of the floor but we're not
done with our calculation we want to
figure out how many of these tiles will
fit into this area and so the general
rule of thumb because you don't want to
lose information the general rule of
thumb is don't round to significant
figures until you are done with your
calculation until you are done
especially if you're just doing a mulch
a bunch of multiplying and dividing
because
otherwise if you round here you actually
will introduce more error into your
calculation than you'd want to so what
you do is you keep it as kind of the
full number now you do the division so
let's do the division so the tiles the
tiles per floor the tiles per I guess we
could say my bathroom or tiles in the
bathroom tiles fitting in bathroom in
the floor of this bathroom it would be
the area of the bathroom so one hundred
twenty one point nine zero seven feet
squared divided by the area of the tile
divided by one point zero seven feet
squared and once again let me get the
calculator out and so we have one twenty
one point nine zero seven divided by one
point zero seven and you get this crazy
thing with all of these digits but this
is going to be our final answer so here
we do care about significant figures so
tiles fitting in the bathroom we get
something that actually just keeps going
so it's let me write this in a new color
we get one hundred thirteen point nine
three one seven seven five seven zero
one and it actually just keeps going
feet squared and since this is the final
answer we're care about how many tiles
will fit on to this bathroom floor now
the significant figures come into play
and the way to think about this is I
have four significant figures over here
I have two significant figures over here
I have three significant figures over
here and since we did just a bunch of
multiplying and dividing and in general
well since we did a bunch of multiplying
and dividing we have to have the minimum
whatever is the minimum significant
figures of the things that we computed
with that's how many significant figures
we can have in our final answer oh and
let me make it clear this isn't two
significant figures this is three the
one the zero and the one so our final
answer can only have three significant
figures three significant figures so we
need to round to the nearest foot the
next that's the next digit over is a
nine so we're going to round up so we're
going to round up so this will get us to
114 actually this units here aren't in
square feet this is in tiles this is
feet divided by feet and so this is
going to be 114
114 tiles obviously it's not going to be
exactly 114 tiles but based on the
precision of the measurements we've done
we can say 114 tiles now what I've just
showed you right here is when we
multiply and divide measurements that
have a certain number of significant
figures the general rule of thumb is
whatever is the you know the minimum
number of significant figures in any of
the numbers are calculated that's how
many significant figures well I guess
the least number is the number of
significant figures in your final
quotient or product or answer when you
do addition and subtraction it's a
little bit different and we'll cover
that in the next video